son influence à lui s'étend sur le monde
des arts depuis une soixantaine d'années
bennes et de retour à la fondation du
doute de Blois à 87 ans l'un des
représentants du mouvement Fluxus
fourmis de nouvelles citations en noir
et blanc pour notre plus grand plaisir
rencontre avec Audrey Champigny
ces trois lettres ben sont connus dans
le monde entier
Benjamin Vautier de son vrai nom en a
fait sa signature
issue d'une famille d'artistes il se
passionne très jeune pour l’écriture le
dessin les performances mais à
contre-courant de son époque dans les
années 60 il rejoint le mouvement
artistique flux
à la fois avant-gardiste et postm mêlant
humour et dérision
qui m'en est choquées qui vont les
étonner qui suis-je pourquoi ou je vais
essayer de trouver des
données moi je vous rappelle ma première
exposition mais il y avait des tableaux
des autres les absactions et je suis le
parti je dis mais il faut que je ma
place et j'ai écrit regardez-moi ne
regardez pas les autres
donc c'était une provocation
et j'ai dit quand même la vérité et
c'était quand même de l'ego l'ego
justement et le thème principal de sa
dernière exposition à la fondation du
doute à Blois un lieu avec lequel il
garde une relation particulière puisque
c'est lui qui illustrera la façade en
1995 la recouvrant de ses œuvres à
l'intérieur des créations d'artistes
insolites déroutante avec souvent cette
idée d'expérimentation
comme son nom l'indique fondation du
doute c'est basé sur le doute mais le
doute créatif c'est-à-dire celui qui
fait que on se pose effectivement des
questions donc on est sûr de rien et
quand on est sur le rien tout est
possible et à partir de là comme quand
tout est possible demain voilà on a plus
qu'à créer des choses sans se poser trop
de questions existentielles ou et d'être
capable de ancrer notre environnement en
crée notre vie et finalement donc nous
sommes des êtres créatifs
fermez plusieurs mois pour rénovation la
fondation du doute a rouvert ses portes
cet été quant à l'exposition de Ben elle
est à découvrir jusqu'au 27 novembre
[Musique]